- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today's message is "Do it for a reason."
Over to you, Notorious B.I.G.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
- Whatever you going to do,
just do it for a reason.
You know what I'm
sayin'? Don't be the fool
that just sit back and do it
'cause somebody else thought it.
Because only thing you
going to do is follow
in somebody else's footsteps
and you're just going to be
a shadow who will be shadow
for the rest of their life.
You know what I'm sayin'?
If you got a little somethin'
that you know how to do,
progress at it, keep
tryin', I mean, God knows
what could happen, you
know what I'm sayin'?
That's what I did.
's kept on rappin',
just happened to get to the right ears.
You know what I'm sayin'?
- If you look at anybody who's had success
in whatever field they're in,
they've done it for a reason.
It wasn't just try to
make money, it wasn't
just tryin' to beat somebody else,
it wasn't just tryin'
to make their parents
or their friends or somebody else happy,
and that, that's the worst reason.
If you're doing something, just to try
to make your parents happy, or friends,
or somebody else's expectations,
it never works out.
You never hit it big.
You're always playing small
because it's not your dream.
It's not your goal.
You'll have some success, but
you'll have small success here
where you really should be
killing it way over here.
You have to have a powerful reason.
And this is what separates
you from everybody else.
Because your reason is
as unique as you are.
Why you want to do something
is customized to yourself.
And that's where you're going
to have the most success,
by following the thing
that gets you excited,
that applies your reason
to your business, your career path,
wherever you end up going.
I love entrepreneurs. I
believe in entrepreneurs.
I'm doing it in my way.
I'm creating and expressing
how Evan Carmichael creates and expresses.
And as long as I am true to
myself, nobody will beat me,
because you can't out-Evan Evan.
And I can't out-you you.
So you got to find you,
because that's how you win.
If I look at you and I
can't tell the difference
between everybody else,
and all you're doin'
is following the best practices
and not modelling them,
and not applying them and twisting them
to make it work for you,
and creating something
that hasn't existed before,
then you're always going to be a shell.
You're always going to
have minor wins instead of
big, huge, empire-like victories.
And so I think that's really
important for any entrepreneur,
for anybody, really,
but for entrepreneurs,
to find your reason.
To understand why you're doing this.
To ask yourself, looking
yourself in the mirror
and why am I doing this?
And you better have a really good reason,
and if you don't, if you don't
have a really good reason,
for why you're doing
the thing you're doing,
that's why you're not having any success.
Alright?
If you're not further ahead, if you're not
where you want to be,
if you're not crushing
on your goals, I'd
really examine your why.
And ask yourself, do I
have a really strong reason
to keep doing this?
Because if you don't, you're
never going to hit it big.
So the question of the
day today is, I'm curious,
what is your reason for
why you do what you do?
What is your big reason?
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Harminder.
Thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, "Your One Word".
It really, really, really, really means
a lot to me and I hope you enjoy it.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you. I hope
you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'